l'an dernier surplus de 1600 mineurs
déférés au parquet de Bobigny seul 130
aurait été écroué le problème de la
Seine-Saint-Denis c'est qu'il y a plus
de mineurs délinquants et quand vous
avez vu les déclarations d'un magistrat
qui exerce en Seine-Saint-Denis disant
que sa politique c'était pas de mettre
en prison les délinquants il est certain
qu'on peut continuer à arrêter des
délinquants si on ne l'aimait pas en
prison et si on en tire aucune
conséquence il y a pas de chance que ça
marche je n'ai pas exemple pas trouvé
admissible
que durant toutes les émeutes du mois de
novembre dernier le tribunal pour
enfants de Bobigny n'est pas prononcé
une seule décision d'emprisonnement